vous le savez moi j'étais dans le
précédent gouvernement conseiller au
ministère de la santé on en aura rêvé
d'avoir ces moyens supplémentaires
je le dis on en aurait rêvé d'avoir ces
moyens supplémentaires mais c'est vrai
mais bien sûr que c'est vrai et je les
assume
on en aurait rêvé de pouvoir donner ces
moyens supplémentaires à l'hôpital
public et aujourd'hui on y arrive
évidemment c'est à la faveur de cette
crise oui c'est vrai que cette crise a
sans doute permis à la société a sans
doute permis aux gouvernements aux
responsables politiques d'ouvrir les
yeux davantage sur cette situation
peut-être que oui cette crise est une
opportunité d'avancer encore plus vite
que c'était prévu avec ma santé 2022
mais il faut le reconnaître c'est un
progrès majeur historique
il n'y a pas eu ces dernières années ces
dernières décennies un tel progrès aussi
rapide pour l'hôpital public pour les
conditions salariales de ses personnels
et pour les moyens qui sont donnés à la
tropicale public pour fonctionner dans
notre pays
et oui ce sont des raisons d'espérer que
notre système hospitalier que notre
système de santé puisse avancer avec
confiance vers l'avenir